ah
here we go again
it's time to return to the acid-filled
containment chamber of scp-682
more commonly known as the hard to
destroy reptile we've spoken about him
and the ways the scp foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then we really
only scratched the surface of the huge
number of insane ways the foundation has
tried to wipe this cranky lizard off the
face of the earth today we're filling in
some of the cracks and taking a look at
the secret test logs detailing the
foundation's unsuccessful quest to
finally destroy
scp-682
some of these may surprise you and if
you're a real scp expert you may just
recognize some familiar faces we meet
along the way esteemed foundation
researcher dr alto clef famed for his
somewhat unconventional personality
entered the test chamber to see if he
could intimidate the beast to death this
resulted in a long-staring contest
between dr clef ann 682 towards the end
of the competition dr clef began to lose
his nerve he tried to leave the room
only to find that the door was locked
causing him to swear loudly dr clef who
always tries to find the most direct
solution to his problems blew up the
door with plastic explosives and ran off
the result test failed next came
scp-662 a silver handbell that summons
the supernaturally helpful butler mr
deeds when mr deeds was summoned
foundation researchers asked him if he
could kill scp-682
deeds politely explained that he
wouldn't be capable of killing 682 it's
just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test
failed the foundation brought in scp-689
a terrifying soapstone statue of a
sitting skeleton that can kill you if
you see it and then stop paying
attention to it 682 first observed the
statue
and then the foundation turned off the
lights when they turned them back on
scp-682 appeared to be dead in a puddle
of gray and black liquid d-class
personnel were sent in to confirm that
682 was actually dead but it instead got
up and killed them researchers theorized
that 682's definition of life is not
quite the same as ours rendering 689's
death-related powers ineffective test
failed yet again
scp-807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon-colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words last chance diner
printed on the edges in white any food
placed on it becomes irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate cardiac arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
682 special 10 kilograms of rotten mead
and sharpened bone splinters 10 liters
of rancid mayonnaise 1 liter of
potassium cyanide and 1 kilogram of
morphine hydrochloride combined into a
solid mass and transmuted by 807 when
682 consumed this disgusting meal it
appeared to collapse however when
d-class personnel were sent in again to
see whether 682 was truly out for the
count multiple holes opened up in its
body these holes fired out high-pressure
jets of blood killing the nearby
d-classes and destroying the containment
cell 682 was fine afterwards another
test failed to kill 682 it seemed that
the foundation really needed to have god
on their side so they tried to recruit
scp-343
also known as god to help them destroy
the beast however when he entered the
containment chamber he somehow couldn't
even see the beast when researchers
asked him whether he could kill 682 god
replied he's not one of mine deal with
him yourself test failed before it even
began next the foundation recruited
scp-524
a small white rabbit that can eat
literally anything including itself
without being harmed the rabbit was
released into scp-682's chamber at which
point it approached 682 and began to eat
one of its legs 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall out of 524's reach
where it remained for a number of hours
at this point scp-524 seemed to become
bored and began eating its way out of
containment through a nearby wall test
failed maybe the luck of the irish was
what the foundation needed to finally
put this monster to rest they recruited
scp-1933 a fat man dressed as santa
claus whose bodily fluids consist
entirely of the alcoholic beverage known
as irish cream if enough of this man's
self-produced irish cream is fed to
something they'll find that all of their
bodily fluids have become irish cream
too killing them the foundation fed
large quantities of this irish cream to
scp-682 and it actually had an effect
causing 682 to appear intoxicated which
was a promising sign however it soon
vomited out a massive quantity of
scp-1933 bodily fluids turning the walls
of its cell into irish cream and
allowing it to escape and wreak havoc
test failed big time the foundation
recruited the help of scp-2337
an intelligent corn creek known as dr
spanko with a voice so loud it can quite
literally talk its victims to death if
it speaks to them for an extended period
of time it was sent into
scp-682's chamber to attempt to destroy
the beast but 682 just told it to leave
and the talkative bird obliged by
blowing away one of the chamber walls
with a yell allowing scp-682 to breach
containment again terrible job dr spanko
test failed the foundation researchers
were starting to get a little frustrated
with their lack of progress which you
can no doubt sympathize with and they
even pitched the possibility of sending
scp-682 into an alternate dimension
where perhaps it would enter into a
stalemate against its alternate self but
this pitch was shot down by the o5
council on the grounds that it was way
way way way too risky back to the
drawing board by which we mean they
literally transformed 682 skin into a
kind of drawing board
scp-2521 is an anomaly that manifests
any time information about it is
recorded and immediately grabs the
source of the information wrapping it in
its tendrils and taking it away with it
the foundation sought to take advantage
of this by using a laser cutter to cut
this anomalous information into
scp-682's side however this didn't have
the results they were hoping for
scp-2521 did turn up to take the
information but it only took the skin on
which the information was carved 682
survived and quickly grew back its skin
test failed again researchers suggested
tracking down scp-169
an obscenely massive underwater creature
known as the leviathan and feeding 682
to the beast however this idea was also
immediately shot down by the o5 council
if 682 did what it did best which was
surviving attacks and adding them to its
own arsenal then it might grow to the
size of scp-169
which would likely trigger an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario it simply was
not worth the risk test failed before it
even started the foundation released two
specimens of scp-939 into 682's test
chamber these voice-imitating
amnesia-inducing monsters have caused
huge damage to human targets so it was
hoped that they may be able to do
something to 682 but this hope turned
out to be misplaced both specimens
seemed extremely distressed by 682's
presence and refused to engage at all
682 did not share the same apprehension
about attacking it charged in and
brutally killed both before devouring
their corpses test failed in a very well
documented case the adorable scp-999 was
introduced into 682's test chamber the
unassailable good vibes provided by 999
as well as an intense tickle fight did
actually lead to the temporary
incapacitation of scp-682
however the otherwise wholesome incident
ended in tragedy when 682 adapted to the
good vibes and was able to release a
kind of violent laughter wave this
incapacitated much of the staff and
allowed 682 to breach containment and go
on another killing spree before being
recontained test once again failed the
next test involved scp-294
an anomalous coffee machine that can
produce any liquid typed into its keypad
foundation researchers requested scp-682
killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results
during tests on the liquid with
scp-682 tissue samples the liquid was
surprisingly effective and caused the
682 tissue to decay and crumble tests on
the living creature were similarly
promising the acid in 682's tank was
temporarily lowered and one liter of
scp-682 killer was poured onto the
reptile's head causing that portion of
its flesh to immediately decay when the
acid was returned the same portion that
had the liquid poured on it dissolved
instantly test well not quite successful
but promising and requiring further
research foundation scientists believe
that if they could one day get a large
enough quantity of this liquid they
might have a viable option but until
then the tests march on for another
experiment they introduced
scp-055 into the containment chamber of
scp-682 scp-055
also known as the self-keeping secret is
a mysterious anomaly that can only be
described by what it isn't for example
we know that
scp-055 is not round but that was pretty
much it now however we know something
else about scp-055
that it can't kill scp-682
test failed but at least we know twice
as much about
scp-055 as we did before next came
scp-082 better known as fernand the
cannibal ferdinand was first presented a
piece of flesh from 682 but rather than
eating it he inspected it and began to
express joy that his friends still live
when introduced into 682's testing
chamber ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
ferdinand and the idea of being ridden
like a pony and the two of them engaged
in combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an scp who responded to reason
much better scp-049
the plague doctor this sinister surgeon
can kill with a touch and the foundation
hoped that his abilities would extend to
682 however the result was a dud the
plague doctor did touch 682 but it
experienced no adverse effects and
eventually swiped at the doctor upon
leaving 049 reported feeling emotionally
disturbed by his encounter with scp-682
yep you guessed it test failed if it
gives you any indication of just how
desperate the researchers were at this
point dr graham pondered whether
introducing 682 to a human with just as
pessimistic and misanthropic feelings as
itself would somehow pacify it they sent
in a particularly nasty d-class and the
two spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't
attempt to harm this d-class they just
shared their profane and bleak
sentiments about the human race with one
another however some of 682's opinions
were a little too spicy for this d-class
after listening to the reptile speak for
20 minutes the d-class fell into a
catatonic state from the sheer
depression of it all he died not long
after one researcher suggested perhaps
the worst idea of all letting
scp-682 out into the wild not even
really to terminate it just to see what
it does the scientists figured there
would be some merit in analyzing the
creature's behavior this idea was
submitted anonymously of course it seems
even the most sadistic of researchers
know better than to put their name on an
idea like that as you can probably guess
this request was shot down by the o5
council the note attached to the request
by one of its members summed it up best
i'll tell you what it will do it'll go
out for a nice stroll murder a few
innocent people go fishing slaughter a
few more innocent people start up a tech
company eat a few more innocent people
go on a vacation to florida dismember a
few more innocent people i swear when i
find out who wrote this you can
personally enter 682's containment
chamber to analyze him yourself this has
been far from an exhaustive account of
all the different ways the scp
foundation has tried to terminate
scp-682
but it shouldn't be surprising that all
of their ideas have either been failures
or were too risky to even try sadly for
the scp foundation and the human race
it's likely we'll be dealing with
scp-682 for a long time to come but do
you have an idea for how you think 682
could finally be killed something that
even the foundation hasn't thought of to
try let us know in the comments and then
go check out scp-682
ways the foundation tried to kill the
hard-to-destroy reptile and
scp-999 the tickle monster for more
fascinating facts about this lizard with
anger issues